The hottest job on the market right now
is a copywriter who does meta ads. Wait,
what is this?
Hold on, I'm getting a getting a
beeping.
I'm sorry, what is it called?
Creative strategist?
What uh what exactly is a creative
strategist?
Someone who who writes ads, tests
angles, scales the winners.
Okay, correct me if I'm wrong, but that
sounds exactly like a copywriter for
meta ads. Am I taking crazy pills here?
All right, funny intro, but welcome back
to the channel. And in today's video,
I'm going to be talking about what is
genuinely the hottest job in marketing
right now, the creative strategist
position, which if you didn't catch it
from the intro, is actually just a
copywriter who does meta ads. But,
there's a reason we got here. There's a
reason there's such demand for this
position. And in this video, I'm going
to tell you exactly what happened that
made this the hottest job in the market.
What exactly is a creative strategist?
And I'm going to give you a crash course
on how you as a copywriter can
absolutely dominate this role for your
clients and put some big bucks in your
pocket. It's kind of funny because for
the last 5 years, I've actually been
running meta ads for some very serious
big brands. In fact, I've spent over 14
million dollars running meta ads. I've
created well over a thousand ads, and I
even wrote, recorded, and trained two
big agencies on this meta ad shift back
in October 2025. But, now that we're
here, I want to give away all my secrets
of what I've personally been doing to
absolutely dominate meta ads in this new
Andromeda era, which I'll talk about in
a second. But, we've got a lot to cover,
so let's dive right in. First off, what
happened? Why is this such a big
demanding position right now? Well,
here's the story. Back in October 2024,
Meta, Zuckerberg, dropped a new AI
algorithm called Andromeda. It's about a
year and a half ago. And he slow rolled
that out as a test phase with some of
the meta ads accounts. And after testing
it with a small number of accounts for
about a year in October 2025, he rolled
out AI Andromeda across the board for
all meta business ads accounts. So,
every single company in the world that
was using meta ads to sell stuff is now
forced to use their new AI algorithm
called Andromeda. Well, this completely
changed the way that advertising had
been done on meta because the old way,
here's how it worked. You would have a
meta ad specialist maybe agency or
freelancer. That person would create two
or three ads a month. They'd have a
budget and they would specify the
targeting of those ads. So, they would
say, "Here's three ads, here's a
thousand bucks, and I want you to show
these ads to 25 to 35-year-old women who
like yoga." And meta would be like,
"Wee, okay, yeah, no problem. I'm going
to show it to those people for you." And
then the budget would basically split
between the three ads and it would show
it to those people and all is well and
good. Well, in October 2025 when meta
rolled out Andromeda, Andromeda said, "I
don't care about your targeting. You
don't know anything about your people. I
know your people better than you know
your people." Which is actually kind of
true because it knows a scary amount of
stuff about your people. And so it said,
"Don't give me this budget targeting
bullcrap. What I want you to do, okay my
dear friend." I don't know why AI
Andromeda is Hulk Hogan. "What I want
you to do, my dear friend, is I want you
to upload 30 ads and I will tell you who
I'm going to show it to and I'm going to
tell you which one of those ads are
losers and which one of those ads are
winners." And it basically absolved this
entire idea of targeting. You don't put
in targeting anymore. Andromeda decides
the targeting based on the ad. So,
whatever ad you create, it's going to
scan the system of meta, Facebook,
Instagram and it's going to say, "Oh, I
know exactly who would like this ad."
Because it knows all the things about
all the people. But, that created a huge
problem because now for meta's AI
algorithm Andromeda to work, it needs a
lot more ads to test against those
people. It gobbles them ads down. It
needs so many more. So, instead of two
to three ads a month, it's more like 20
to 30 ads a month, which created this
huge problem in these companies because
they now have to make 20 to 30 ads a
month, and they don't have anybody to do
it. They're already stacked. So, a bunch
of these big brands tried to figure out,
well, what are we going to do? And they
posted and created a job called the
creative strategist, someone who creates
and writes ads at the pace of 20 to 30
ads a month to fulfill the Meta Ads
Andromeda algorithm, which at the end of
the day, again, is just a sexy name for
a copywriter who does Meta Ads because
it's writing ads, thinking of different
hooks, angles, and ideas, AB testing
those ads, figuring out which ones work
and which ones don't, scaling the
winners and killing the losers. But that
doesn't mean it doesn't have its own set
of problems because those 20 to 30 ads a
month that they're freaking out about,
now they're hiring you to solve, and you
have to figure out how to create 20 to
30 ads a month. Not only that, you're
not just creating 20 to 30 ads a month,
you have to create ads that actually
work and convert and sell stuff.
Otherwise, you're going to get fired,
lose this client, not make any money.
And lucky for you, your boy El Capigo
has been doing this for a very long
freaking time. So, I put together a very
simple crash course to help you come up
with the best ad idea possible. Now,
what I have on my screen is the creative
strategist crash course. This is a cheat
sheet for you, which by the way, I put a
link down in the description below so
you can download it and have it on your
desktop, print it, whatever you want to
do. So, that way when you go do the
creative strategist role, you can have
this idea generating machine like this.
All right, we've got a lot to cover. So,
let's dive into what this looks like.
The first thing that I want to dive into
is the four big swings to test. In the
old Meta Ads Andromeda, people would be
testing things like colors and fonts and
all these little tweaks. Well, you don't
test tweaks anymore, you test swings,
okay? You don't test like a little tap,
it's a big thing that you're going to
test to make it more obvious of what's
working and what's not working. And
these big four things are actually more
emotional than logistical or systematic,
okay? Let me break down what that looks
like. The first one is the biggest pain.
What you want to do is you want to
figure out what is the one pain that is
costing your people sanity, sleep, or
money. That pain is going to be your ad.
Let me give you some examples from a
brand called AG1. AG1 is like a health
supplement. You scoop one scoop, put it
in some water, shake it, drink it. A lot
of you probably know what AG1 is, which
is why I'm using it as an example. So,
for AG1, let's look at the pain examples
that we may be able to use in ads. Like,
one, they're exhausted all day, but they
can't figure out why. That's an ad. They
know that their diet is garbage, but
eating healthy food feels impossible
with their schedule, tight schedule,
timelines. They've got a drawerful of
supplements that they never take. Or,
their gut is constantly bloated or
sluggish, and nothing they've tried has
fixed it. Or, they have this low-grade
anxiety that they're not doing enough to
take care of themselves. All five of
those pains are ads. And what you're
trying to figure out is what is the
biggest pain that resonates with your
audience that's going to get them to
click the ad, land on your website, and
consider taking AG1. The next huge swing
that you want to test is the biggest
desire. What do they really want right
now? What's a promise that's like, man,
if I had that, I would be I would be
dreaming happy right now. Well, let's
talk about AG1 again. So, some big
desires that they may want in this
health supplement is they want to last
through the day without having to take a
2:00 p.m. coffee just to survive it. Oh
my gosh, all day energy. Or, they want
to feel like they've got their health
handled without spending 8 hours a day
counting their macros and and putting in
their calories and all these things.
Like, they don't want to do this stuff.
Or, they want to feel very sharp, clear,
locked in like they did in their 20s.
They want to feel young again. Or, they
want to look in the mirror and be like,
man, I'm I'm looking good. I'm feeling
young. I'm looking happy. Or they just
want peace of mind that they're actually
doing something every single day to take
care of their body. Those are desires.
Now, I will tell you, pain is always
going to outsell a desire. Desire does
well, but pain is the number one driver
of clicks on ads. You want to be careful
on how you use pain, but pain is going
to outdrive desire 10 out of 10 times.
But a desire is a good balance cuz
again, if you're creating 20 to 30 ads a
month, you need to have that variety,
those big swings in your test. Which
leads me to the next one is the biggest
fear. What is the thing that your people
are dreadfully scared might come true?
That is a fear for them. Which by the
way, pain and fear, while similar,
they're not the same thing and they are
parallel. I'm going to give you some
examples in a sec, but pain and fear
will always outpull desire. Some
examples of fear is they're terrified
that they're going to wake up at 55 and
realize that they've been neglecting
their health their whole life. They're
scared that their low energy and brain
fog is a sign that something is
seriously wrong with them. Or they fear
that they're slowly becoming a shell of
who they used to be physically and that
the best version of themselves is
already behind. Or they're afraid that
no matter whatever they try, that
nothing's actually going to work and
they're just going to feel stuck feeling
this way forever. Or last one, they're
terrified that they're are going to end
up spending $500 a month on supplements
and all of it is trash. Every single one
of those is ad. I just gave you 15 ad
ideas just off these swings. But let's
go ahead and ramp it up to 20 with one
that I like to call crazy contrast,
okay? You have to say something so
polarizing that no one else in your
market has the balls to say it. But it
has to match your brand. The way you say
it and what you say has to match how
your brand would say it. Let me give you
some examples for AG1 again, okay? So
for AG1, they may run an ad that says
supplements suck. And then they talk
about in this one scoop, you get 86
supplements, right? Like you don't want
to be taking a drawer full of
supplements and cabinets full of
supplements. You want to take this one
scoop. So, they could say something
polarizing that would catch someone's
attention and be like supplements suck
cuz they've always heard supplements are
good. Or the next one, uh you could be
healthy in 1 minute per day. That's
polarizing. That's polarize because
everybody Oh, you got to work out. You
got to drink water. You got to do all
this, which are all good things, by the
way. But, they can say that because it
takes 1 minute to scoop greens and you
could be much healthier. Or coffee is
destroying you. Oh my gosh, the coffee
people would freak out. Your doctor is
lying to you. They're prescribing you
this. They're prescribing you that when
really have you even taken care of the
greens in your diet? And they talk about
AG1. Or the health industry wants you
confused, right? Stuff like this, crazy
contrast is basically just taking what
do 90% of people believe that your brand
doesn't believe and you can say that
thing, okay?
Again, it has to tie to your product to
how your product solves the thing you're
talking against. And if you need help
figuring out pains, fears, desires,
things like that, I already made another
video, okay? This is a clickable link.
You can get the link in the description
below or when you download this cheat
sheet, it's in there for you. So, you
could just hover over this and you could
click it and it will take you to my
secret AI hack for rapid market
research. It'll take you about 15
minutes to do and we'll have Gemini take
care of all the market research for you
and give you hundreds of ideas on pains,
fears, desires, and crazy contrast, all
that stuff taken care of for you inside
of this cheat sheet. Next is you want to
test the different ad types. So, now
that we've tested big swings, which are
more like emotional things, ad types is
the styles of the ads that you can
actually create themselves. This is a
little bit more of the tactics in here.
So, the first way is you might do a
listical, something like this, Which by
the way, I didn't create this ad. These
are examples. Just want to clarify that.
But a listical is a numbered list that
highlights the the benefits, the
problems, or the tips. You might do
something for AG1 that's like five
reasons your gut hurts. Or this one,
five natural ways to love your gut. And
it may look like a listical like this,
and you can even write the listical in
the copy. Another one might be an
advertorial. This ad I did create for my
good friend Carrie Overburner, who is a
number one best-selling author. This is
more like a Wall Street Journal-style ad
that it looks like I'm promoting news,
but it actually goes to an article,
which then embeds a link to his book.
But I also wrote the ad long-form. I
didn't write it like an ad. I wrote it
like an article in the ad copy itself.
So it read like a Wall Street Journal,
so they didn't know they were reading an
ad. They thought they were reading news.
The next one is direct response. This is
Shady Rays, and they're just doing a buy
one get one. This is direct response.
Hey, here's our product, go ahead and
buy it. There's very limited copy here.
It talks about the free shipping. It's a
just a very simple, straightforward ad.
The next one is a quiz. Here's one I did
create. So this one was for my friends
over at Missio and Faithworks. They help
Christians and Christian nonprofits with
their meta ads. And so we may run a test
that says, "Hey, take a free quiz to see
if you're overspending on ads."
Overspending on ads is a big pain point
for that audience. We're taking a quiz
to see how big that pain is. You could
do the same thing for desire. You could
do the same thing for fear. Here's a UGC
ad. UGC means user-generated content. So
it looks and feels and tastes like
normal content, but it's actually an ad
for what they're reviewing. So you may
have these ladies who's reviewing maybe
a supplement, or this lady is doing
Skims bras, or whatever. And she's
reviewing the content, and it looks like
she's just at her house and just doing
normal stuff on her iPhone, but it's
definitely an ad. The next one is
problem-solution.
You want to start with a very specific
pain point, agitate that pain, and then
attach the solution to it. So, this one
actually kind of combines the the
biggest pain and the biggest desire. You
can kind of mesh those into one ad.
Ormosi does this amazing. So, he does
with a headline, "Are you struggling to
scale?" That's a big pain point. And
then he teaches, "To scale, you need one
of these three things." So, he's
teaching it. Here's the solution. Ba ba
ba ba ba ba. And then his ad is, "I can
help you solve this problem." Right? So,
problem solution in the ad itself. And
then another one of my favorites is a
storymation, okay? Which is story plus a
transformation. Somebody who's taken
your product, they have transformed
themselves from one person to another
person based on your product. That's a
storymation. You tell the story of their
transformation. So, this is an ad from
V-Shred where this guy went from a 6XL
to looking like this, absolutely jacked
and shredded. Great ad. Which actually
bonus, they did a storymation tied to a
quiz, which I thought was genius. So,
they told this story, told the
transformation, and then say, "Take this
1-minute quiz to see if you would be a
good fit for our program." And the last
one is an irresistible offer. This is
different than a direct response. So,
when you went to direct response, we saw
something like this, buy one get one.
That's an enticing offer. It calls for
the action and it says, "Hey, buy my
thing." But an irresistible offer is
something like this where it's like
you're saving $308.
It's this this this this boom boom boom
boom. And it's a stack that is a flash
stack that looks like, "Man, if I don't
get this now." And it has this deadline
with it, only while supplies last, or
you could do ends in 7 days. This is a
great way to get a jolt of sales right
off the rip. Again, another one from
V-Shred. Now, we're going to take those
ad types and those big swings, and we're
going to turn it into an infinite idea
flywheel so that you can create those 20
to 30 ads per month. The first thing
that you need to do is you need to
understand pairings, okay? You can take
the ad type, you can take the big swing,
and now you can pair them to create a
new ad. So, an example might be you take
the biggest pain
plus UGC content, bam, that's a new ad.
Or you do the biggest desire into a list
with a listical, bam, that's a new ad.
Crazy contrast plus a quiz, bam, that's
a new ad. And then you just combine four
big swings times the eight ad types,
bada bing bada boom, you got infinite
because the other thing that you could
do is you could take the one big swing
and test it against all eight ad types.
That's eight ads themselves. You could
test the second desire and test it
against all eight ad types, and you just
go and go and go. The next thing you can
do is you can mix it up with different
formats. You can do videos, which is by
the way the number one performing on
meta ads, or you could do just really a
high-quality photograph. You could do a
graphic design. You could do a carousel.
So, now you can do a biggest pain
listical four different ways, which
leads me to how you scale the winners
because you're going to be talking to
these clients, and they're going to be
like, "Hey, which ads are working? Which
ads are not working?" And the way that
you scale the winners is once you figure
out which ads are working, which by the
way a good hint for whatever ads are
working is a two to five x ROAS, meaning
return on ad spend, then your ads are
working. If you're getting less than
that, they are not working. A good
example of this being if you're spending
$100 on ads, but you're getting $200 in
sales, that's a two x ROAS. If you're
spending $100 on ads, and you're getting
$500 in sales, it's a five x ROAS. If
you're getting above that, you're an
absolute G, and people should be paying
you a lot of money. So, with the scaling
winners, what you actually want to do is
you want to find the big swing that
wins, and then test it with all the
different ad types. So, if you figure
out that fear is your biggest big swing
that actually wins, you want to test
fear in all eight formats, direct
response, listical, advertorial, and so
on and so on and so on. And then you can
mix it up with the different styles,
whether it's a carousel, it's a video,
things like that. So that way you got
16, 20, 25 ads right there just off your
winner. And then you're trying different
hooks of that pain. So if it's pain that
won, now go try the other four pains
against the eight types of listicles
with the four different formats. There
you go, another 30 ads. Then choose
another pain, eight types of ads, four
types of formats, another 30 ads. And if
you ever run out of ideas, you can use
some of the tools in this library. The
first one is the Facebook Ads Library.
I'm going to help you figure this out
right now. So Facebook Ads Library, if I
click this link, which is in here, it's
going to take you over here to this
page, and I can type all ads, and I can
go in here, and I can see any ad that
anybody in my niche is running. So if I
want to go see Alex Hormozi and see what
ads is Alex Hormozi running here, I can
go see every single ad, school, anybody
that mentions Hormozi, I can actually
even find his account and see what he's
running, and see Alex Hormozi has been
running these ads for a long time. And
one of the things that you want to look
for is you want to see the oldest ads he
is running or anyone is running. So I
see this ad, he's been running this one
since October 17th, 2025. Well, that's
almost 6 months from the time of this
video, which tells me this ad is doing
amazing, because nobody would spend
money to keep an ad going if it's not
doing well. So if I see an ad that is,
let's see, February 23rd, I'm assuming
this one's not doing as good or March
17th, this one's not doing as good as
October 17th, because this one's been
longer. So the longer the ads are
running, the better indicator that they
are working. The next tool is a forecast
creator. This was created by my good
friend Andrew Spikes, who's the CEO of a
company called Missio Marketing. This is
going to be helpful for you, especially
if you work with clients, because one of
the things that clients are going to
wonder is, are these ads working? And
you have to align the priorities and the
actual performance with these clients.
So one of the things I like to do is
come in here, and you can actually
create a forecast for how your ads may
do based on their budget, industry, and
things like that. So, if we do meta ads,
let's go with meta ads, and let's say uh
what we're actually trying to do is
we're trying to get them to do a uh
e-commerce purchase. Their budget is
$10,000 a month. Their customer lifetime
value, let's say is $500. Their average
order value is $200.
And then let's pick uh let's pick
e-commerce, national medium to
well-known. Well, we should forecast a
6.5
ROAS based on these numbers. Lifetime
ROAS 16 to 25. Our customer acquisition
cost should be 20 to $31, and our
purchases should be here. This is the
number of clicks. So, it's a forecast.
It even tells us what we should expect
in impressions, clicks, purchases. So,
if you are on track for this forecast
based on that, then you can align with
your client be like, "Hey, you're good
with this, right? You're happy If I hit
these numbers, you're happy." And you,
as a creative strategist, also know what
you should expect. Now, something may
change. If they change the budget to
$5,000 a month, and their average order
value drops to $60, and their lifetime
value drops to $200, well, now you know
the difference is, "Hey, it looks like
our purchases are going to be this much
lower. Our ROAS dropped to 1.6 to 2.7,
and we're at a $23 customer acquisition
at best, $38 at worst." This is a
conversation that you can look really
smart with your clients, and I put it
right in here in this tool for you.
Pretty cool, right? And then the last
thing that I want to go through is
common problems. You will run into
common problems. You're launching so
many ads. Your clients are going to
wonder, "Hey, why did this happen? Why
is this not working?" And I'm going to
expose right now what the things they
are going to ask and how to solve them.
The first one being a high CPA. This is
a high cost per acquisition, meaning
whether you're getting leads or sales to
conversions, it's costing more than your
forecast or more than your clients are
expecting. That's the problem. And the
way to fix that problem is the first
way, one, test stronger offers. An offer
is going to be the biggest thing that
gets your customer acquisition to
convert faster. Number two is you want
to simplify the funnel. If it's costing
too much money to acquire the customer,
then chances are your funnel might be
too long or hard, right? It may be going
from a form to a website to a quiz to a
email sequence, and then they get the
sale. The funnel may be broken in all
kinds of ways because every step you
have in your funnel is a place where you
can leave customers, which makes it more
expensive to acquire the customers that
you do want to have. And the third thing
for a high CPA is trying different
creative. I would specifically say
trying the four big swings, right? Try
different pain, try different fear,
because you might not be resonating with
the market, so it's taking a lot longer
for Meta to actually find the right
people who would buy your stuff, which
is costing you more money to find those
people. The next problem is a low ROAS,
a low return. So, if you're not getting
that 2x, 3x, and you're getting that 1,
1.5, or or worse, less than that, you're
actually negative, then that means that
your clients are not making the money
back based on what they're spending.
This is a huge problem. And so, one
thing that I like to do if you are low
on ROAS, the first one is I like to add
upsells in the funnel. Because if we're
spending, let's say, $50 to acquire a
customer, and then they're buying $50
worth of product, one easy way to make
more money is to give them more things
to buy so that the average order value
of when they're buying from you goes
from $50 to $150. So, now it may cost
you $50 to acquire that customer, but
you're making 3x that because you added
good congruent upsells in the funnel.
So, that way you don't even have to
change the ads, you just increase the
upsells. Or number two, you could try a
totally different offer. Maybe this
offer is not resonating, and you try
something attached to a different pain,
a different fear, something that costs
more or has more profit margin. If your
customer acquisition cost is $50, but
you're selling a $25 product, well,
you're losing half your money. But if
your customer acquisition cost is $50
and you're selling a $500 product,
you're gaining money. The other one is
to cut underperforming campaigns. If
you're AB testing different campaigns
and you have one that's ripping it and
one that's absolutely killing you, but
you're still spending money on the one
that's absolutely killing you, well,
turn off the one that's killing you and
spend more money on the one that's
ripping it. And do it faster because
Meta likes to spend your money fast and
you need to look at the account every
day to be like, "Whoa, whoa, whoa. Hey,
don't spend money on that crappy
campaign." The next one is a low
click-through rate. A low click-through
rate means that people are seeing your
ads, you're getting the impressions, but
they're not actually clicking to go to
the next step in your funnel. There's a
couple reasons with this. First off,
it's likely your hook, okay? Your hook
is not catching them. They have to catch
them 3 seconds. You have to remember,
people are scrolling social media and
you have to stop the scroll. So, either
your video, graphic, carousel, whatever
is not visually compelling or your hook
sucks. Try different hooks. Or, again,
another big swing. Big swings are going
to be your biggest lever. Try different
pain, a different fear. You have to find
the right angle that when they hear it,
they're like, "Huh." And they stop and
then they click through. Another one is
bad leads. You are getting leads in your
funnel, but they're not buying any. So,
you may be doing a lead magnet giveaway
and you're getting all these email
subscribers on their email list, but
then when you're actually in Klaviyo and
you're trying to sell them something,
they ain't buying jack. These are what I
would consider bad leads. There's a
couple ways to filter these people out.
Is one, you can add qualifying questions
to whatever opt-in form. So, if you're
sending them to a landing page that's
just asking for their email, maybe ask
for their email, name, and phone number.
It'll get you less leads, but it's more
likely to get you buyers. And what's
more important, leads or money? Number
two is you could clarify the offer in
the ad itself. A lot of times you're
getting leads with this free lead
magnet, but you're not actually having a
congruent offer with that. So, if you
get them based on a lead magnet that
talks about losing weight, but then you
make an offer about building muscle,
those are two different offers. They're
not congruent at all. So, you need to
clarify, the ad has to be congruent with
the offer itself when you're selling it.
And the last one is actually clarifying
the target in your ad. So, remember I
said Andromeda doesn't give a rip about
you putting in targeting, which means
the targeting has to come from
somewhere. And where's that going to be?
That's going to be your ad copy or the
ad itself. You have to say, "Hey,
photographers." Or you have to say,
"Hey, school teachers." You have to put
those things in the ad itself for the
targeting to make sense and Andromeda to
be like, "Oh, okay. Yeah, I see who
you're talking to. Yeah, no problem.
I'll show it to them." And the last one
is fatigue or ad burnout. This is when
the same people have seen the same ad
too many times and they haven't clicked.
In Meta Ads, this is called frequency.
It used to be that you could get to a
frequency of six or seven, meaning the
same person has seen your ad six or
seven times and they haven't clicked.
That means you have ad fatigue. It means
Meta doesn't want to show this ad
anymore because it's shown it and people
are not clicking. Nowadays, it's more
like two or three. And the only way to
solve this is to create more ads, which
is exactly what this cheat sheet helps
you do. But I know that's going to
create another problem cuz you're going
to go create all these ads, you're going
to go get these clients, you're going to
knock them out, or you're going to start
doing this for yourself. Maybe you're a
business owner and you're trying to
knock it out for yourself. I say if you
need some further help than this, I have
a club called Copy Creator Club. I'll
leave a link in the description below.
I'm in there alongside 100 other
copywriters who are insanely good at
marketing and advertising. And so if
you're creating a bunch of ads, you're
running it for your business or you're
running it for your clients, whatever it
else, and you want to get some feedback
on those ads, you want to get those ads
roasted, we have weekly calls in there,
you can post them up for roast, you can
talk to people. I'm in there every
single day, and I will personally help
you make sure that your ads are
absolutely cracking. But no pressure. If
that's not a good fit for you, you can
download this cheat sheet, use the exact
framework that I've given you here, that
I've personally used myself, and I
guarantee you're going to be having some
better ads. Listen, I hope you found
this video really helpful. We blew
through a ton of content really fast. If
you did, do me a quick favor. Like the
video and subscribe to the channel. It
tells me that you want me to make more
valuable content like this. Again, I
appreciate you. Thank you so much.
Everything is down in the link in the
description below. Go grab it, enjoy it,
create some ads, and leave a comment if
you have any questions that I didn't
answer today. I'm happy to respond to
those comments, help you out, get you
cracking. Till then, I'm going to enjoy
this coffee and I'll catch you on the
next one.